um talk about uh for you man how dope
has it kind of been to like when cuz I
feel like when you when I got into radio
in
2005 and I think the first time I might
have saw you live was maybe like 06 or
07 but I was like working at a radio
station in Phoenix when neighborhood
music like popped off like that [__] was
like a real way it was like that you had
the song neighborhood music yeah yeah 20
2004 yeah you had uh bring out the freak
in you trying to think of all your radio
singles that we
played those are the ones that come to
my mind yeah we barely getting by the
God on the radio barely get by was dope
for sure for sure and then obviously
summer nights is summer nights but um at
that same time magic had sexy lady and
obviously MB Riders had what they were
doing is it dope to kind of be able to
like like be side by side with a guy
like magic and be like look how far
we've come like you know what I'm saying
oh yeah yeah we go way back too man we
been in San Diego cuz uh I believe he
wanted to sign me at one point or
something like that there he wanted to
sign you yeah I think so yeah yeah I
think so and work together and stuff and
but end up working with the same label
and we ended up was that upstairs
putting things out yeah upstairs records
yeah yeah they had I mean upstairs
records had everybody so then we uh you
know I would go out to uh I went to
Phoenix to work with with magic and we
did uh California mhm and City everyone
knows um so yeah we work together from
the g- go and then obviously even like a
guy like Baby Bash who's kind of turned
into everyone's favorite like hi Uncle
yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure man I was
just saying man I was on the way here I
was running a little bit late and I was
dressing out a little bit so I started
puffing on a joint that uh the bash's
team gave me so um that cherry wave so
yeah shout out to bash for that bash
passes you weed you got to you just got
to make sure you know oh yeah yeah I
don't smoke like that I smoke you got a
few hours to yourself you know yeah yeah
for sure for sure dog for sure so you're
high right now uh it's a little bit I
feel good to bad couple puffs and that's
it what's your biggest Market these days
like what do you know is like that one
market like no matter what they're
showing out for you well I say I would
say Los Angeles man and it's so big too
where you got you could do a show over
here and over here and over there and
yeah you do like Still rocking there's
so many little areas in La yeah yeah a
big market for me man so even that with
you know hooking up with the ston for
this video and everything almost like
showing love to to La too you know um
yeah of course he's a legend yeah yeah
for sure man and uh you know talking
about getting stuck like uh like uh like
it's a Friday you know in traffic in La
you know what I mean and um you don't
want to get stuck in life did he direct
the new video oh yeah he directed the
new video yeah did you watch his uh
Netflix documentary that they about him
cartoon that [__] was sick do do yeah
cartoon did these for me man the 12 did
128 yeah that's how much was that did he
did he hit you like Peak Mr cartoon
prices for those uh I don't remember man
I think we were just [__] chilling
and listening some moldies and having a
couple beers I feel like back then Mr
cartoon could have charged anything for
a tattoo rappers would have been like
yeah no I think he I think he hooked me
up pretty nicely man it it was dope
thank you shout out to cartoon man
what's up shout out to Mr cartoon man
yeah yeah been a minute been a minute
for sure um ston shot the uh the cover
for uh neighborhood music damn that's
crazy that shot that so that's back in
2004 man wow so we go way back too you
know way back are you aware that like
people kind of look at you as like kind
of like the the Jay-Z of Cho rap do you
like understand that like that's like
cuz whenever we think about Cho rap like
you are the god of it man yeah no I mean
I hear it man but you know just just
always just like going to the studio and
and uh doing my thing man so that part
doesn't really doesn't really uh the
noise and all the like extra [__]
doesn't really come across your radar
not really man I mean it does it comes
across my radar but I don't really like
it's kind of like deflected kind of like
a little bit because it doesn't make
doesn't do me I don't know I got no
opinion on it you know yeah man it's a
trip though but I don't look at myself
like that and I just kind of like and I
think maybe that's why the people dig
what I'm doing I don't know just kind of
works right